a highly contagious form of the bird flu
has been confirmed at several Southern
Nevada Parks several agencies sent out
Health alerts this week
urging everyone to avoid wild geese and
other waterfowl Sasha Loftus spoke with
Park goers and health officials
officials say the two geese that tested
positive for this virus were found here
at Sunset Park you can see signs like
this all over the park warning people to
stay away from the animals and not feed
them what's definite concerned reaction
to local cases of the avian flu it is a
little bit of concerning since my dog
does like to like try to like get them
two Canadian geese tested positive for
the virus this week here at Sunset Park
which has the Nevada Department of
Wildlife and Clark County issuing Health
alerts and posting signs like this uh
it's gonna cause me to take a little
extra precaution when I'm out here in
the future highly pathogenic avian flu
or hpai is dangerous and even deadly to
birds but how worried should people be
people shouldn't be concerned about
Contracting avian flu will Rucker of the
American Lung Association says while
humans can catch the disease it's really
only a threat if you're handling an
animal that's sick unless you're working
on a farm working with poultry directly
the risk of Contracting avian flu is
very very low still he says it's
important to take Extra Care in settings
like this just taking the right
precautions not letting my dog off leash
to keep you and your family safe bring
about a lot more attention so that
people can use
Common Sense Clark County says its Parks
and Recreation staff has been stepping
up patrols and upping their cleaning
procedures getting rid of any droppings
or Birds who have died to prevent this
from spreading any further reporting
from Sunset Park tonight social Loftus 8
News Now